[Music]
this
is breaking news on 8 news now
tracking breaking news here at six
o'clock take a look at this video
fire crews working right now near
decatur and the 95 to put out this
massive blaze
at a local tire shop thanks for joining
us i'm denise valdez i'm david charns
this fire creating smoke scene all
across the valley sasha loftis
is live there with some new information
let's help right outside sasha
denise and david yes this massive fire
luckily put out the flames are out for
now but just
a really huge situation luckily no one
seriously hurt now i'm joined by las
vegas fire and rescue public information
officer tim simanski
so tim you were saying this is really
the biggest fire you guys have seen in
the last couple years so tell me why you
said it's because of this is a as an
auto mechanic shop right
it had a lot of flammable liquids in it
the most being gasoline
several vehicles on a lot the gasoline
tanks ruptured on the lot
caught fire we had flowing gasoline back
there and that's what made this fire so
intense why it was so big
is because of all the flammable liquids
inside the building and you were saying
you know with such a big fire
i mean people could have gotten
seriously hurt here you said two people
with minor injuries but
it's very lucky that no one was
seriously hurt especially it was so busy
people were driving through
this this intersection is completely
full it's rush hour a lot of people in
the shopping center in the mall right
across the street
it's a potential for a lot of people to
get hurt but luckily we had two very
minor injuries
that were treated on the scene and those
people were released thank you so much
and fire's still under investigation as
you said
still just a really a massive situation
firefighters putting out hot spots here
no word on a cause of this fire but of
course we will keep you updated
with the latest both on air and online
eightnewsnow.com so stay with us for
that
one quick note decatur is shut down here
we'll be closed for a little while
longer right near the meadows mall
so if you are driving make sure to avoid
that for now reporting live sasha loftis
8 news now sasha thank you now to